around
let's hit the house
good evening councillors ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to the
extraordinary meeting of traffic council
before we formally start this meeting i
invite my chaplain father gerald murphy
of saint anthony of padua stratford to
lead us in prayer
the gathering began in the name of the
father and the son and the holy spirit
amen
almighty father we ask your presence
and your guidance for the members of our
council
as they meet to deliberate and
and question and seek the very best for
the residents
and the community of the borough
and we ask this through christ our lord
amen amen
thank you father please be seated
first item is apologies i have received
apologies for absence from councillors
bennett lam proctor councillor mersa and
council of whites have had to give
apologies because of their needs to
isolate can i ask if anyone else is
aware
of any other apologies council slater
thank you council accordingly council
accordingly
any other apologies
no thank you
voting and broadcast information
as we are holding our meeting away from
the town hall again
we do not have our normal voting
facilities so any votes this evening
will be by a show of hands
this meeting is also being streamed live
to the council's committee meetings
youtube channel
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
and this activity promotes democratic
engagement
in accordance with section 108 of the
local government act
1972
also like last time i would make members
aware when speaking this evening
that they can either make use of the
roaming microphones or if you prefer to
be more visible on camera
please come forward to the table at the
front to make your speech there
you will be aware of the summons that
the extraordinary meeting has been
specially convened at the request
of the monitoring officer so that the
council may consider
the response to an application made on
behalf
of manchester ship canal company
under the transport and works act in
relation to the rixton and warburton
toll bridge
comments on the application have to be
lodged with secretary of state by the
18th of january
2022
the business this evening will be dealt
with like it would be at an ordinary
meeting
and as such
we shall now proceed with the main item
rixton and warburton toll bridge
transport and works act order
the executive member for housing and
regeneration has submitted both a report
and a supplementary regarding the
manchester ship canal companies
application
and i will invite council of right to
introduce the matter
and move the recommendations councillor
wright please
yep there it is that's fine uh thank you
thank you mr mayor and um happy to move
this report um and recommendations um
just just want to clarify something so
don't forget and get into trouble with
the monitoring officer um but on page
five of the report there is a slight
error which is on the level of toll
proposed amount
um
the it states in the report that the uh
when current rates of vit are factored
in the toll will be one pound 20 this is
in fact incorrect when vit's factored in
the correct toll or the correct proposed
time will actually be one pound so
that's just just for clarity
um i'd just like to thank all members
that have attended this meeting that
short notice i understand that this
particular issue may be quite niche for
many of you
but for those of us who represent this
area or the areas close by this is an
incredibly important document
i won't go into too much detail on the
reporters i'm sure members will have
already read it however this proposal
concerns me greatly
not just is this toll charge proposed
nearly 10 times higher than the current
charge
but for those people who live literally
on the same road as the toll bridge and
likely cross it every single day this is
an unsustainable and frankly ludicrous
proposal
that's not even taken into account the
people who use this bridge from partings
and in my own ward
which we already know is the most
deprived ward in the borough
many people who live in partington
carrington warburton and dunham etcetera
will work across the bridge many in
places such as earlham or further afield
in places such as wigan and warrington
this bridge is their only connectivity
to their job
we also need to remember that this part
of trafford is almost completely devoid
of good and reliable public transport
in fact most buses are not even allowed
to cross the bridge anyway because of
the weight limit
for many owning a car is the only option
i do understand however that we must do
something to alleviate congestion around
the bridge
prior to the covered 19 pandemic and
since the middle of this year until very
recently
the congestion caused by the bridge is
unbearable for local residents and also
for people simply wanting to get to and
from places
the main conceit concern here is local
residents
i've been to countless meetings with
people who live in warburton who have
stated the emergency services cannot
attend to them because of the congestion
when we consider a large proportion of
the housing directly adjacent to the
bridge a bungalow's for older people
this is something that simply cannot
continue
the introduction of ampr and the removal
of the barriers is therefore welcomed
however as a council we cannot be held
to ransom by the manchester ship canal
company for investing in a technology
that should have been in place long ago
twelve and a half p is cheap and maybe
there is a case for a slight rise in the
toll
bringing the toll fee to an amount that
is recognised by the bank of england
would be a start
however a near tenfold increase for
simply crossing a bridge is absolutely
unacceptable
there are many other concerning parts of
this order which are exemplified in the
report including for me manchester ship
canal company having a bill at the
ability to enforce bylaws and having far
too much control over a really really
important part of the road
infrastructure in greater manchester
i would ask members to vote in favor of
the objections laid out from the report
and i'll move the report thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor right are there any
members wishing to speak
counselor
i just can't put everybody out make sure
i don't miss anybody needs to be
seconded yes
and ladies and gents secondly
yeah seconded
um not much to add to this because
councillor wright has
laid the issues out in in detail as he
always does but i do think there are a
couple of pertinent points
pertinent points with regard to
the
paper before us this evening and the
potential impact that this has on
users of the
bridge
firstly that this would remove the
maximum charge of two journeys across
the bridge in one day so there is
currently a 25
cap
there would be no discounts for the
residents of woberton
or indeed partington
the
specific changes allow for an annual
uplift of cpi minus one in the total
charge so where does this end
and also crucially it introduces a
profit-making element to what has always
been a loss-making bridge that implies
that instead of that funding being ring
fence to go into investment into what is
an incredibly aged bridge
would allow for profit to be taken and
away by the company concerned and
finally chair just a brief observation
about the supplementary paper that we
have received and the reason for that
additional um recommendation and that is
that there is a further proposal in this
to convey away from the manchester ship
canal company the ownership of the
governance responsibilities for the
bridge to a distinct
company that raises all sorts of
concerns but primarily one of the
financial sustainability of such a
company and where it would lead us if
they were to run into trouble that adds
an element of risk that we should all be
concerned about for our residents who
rely on that bridge day in day out to
get to work it is a several mile round
trip to find an alternative means of
getting out of that area and away
towards warrington so it is for those
reasons that i support the
recommendations and i'd encourage all
members to do so in order to object to
this proposal which at its heart is an
eight times increase in the toll but
also has further ramifications of both
the financial nature and indeed in terms
of impact on local residents thank you
chair
thank you councillor weston
um yes members wishing to speak i've got
some
names start with councillor jerome
council jerome
thanks chair
um
this bridge does provide a pivotal link
over the river mersey and manchester
ship canal and connects the villages of
rickston and orbiting it plays an
important role for local communities but
also forms a strategic route between the
m6 and the m60
however this bridge was built in 1863
and i think we must accept it is is
probably no longer sustainable or maybe
um you know needs renovation and upkeep
as greens we would like to see
any improvements for future developments
of this bridge consistent with our
climate emergency
um
this does mean that funding must come
from somewhere we recognize that the
toll must rise but we also recognize
that under this current government
is leading us into a cost of living
crisis and the people of the area will
be affected by
by the charges going up
um
but we must be aspirational about having
a bridge that not only supports walking
and cycling but has roots that links to
such networks but we realize toll rises
will have an impact on local people so
it must be balanced but we are
but we are here to
but we are here to either support or
object to traffic council's consultation
response first and foremost we agree
that the power of the mscc to make and
enforce bylaws could lead to excessive
unpaid toll charges that could rise to
as much as 100 pounds
extra time for notice to 21 days seems
perfectly reasonable too
and would be useful for local people
we do believe that the council are right
to question the level of the toll and
the price at which it is capped general
users and local people deserve absolute
clarity on this
it still isn't clear whether vat is
included or not included in the single
one pound fee but i think um that might
have been addressed so
we may have a bit more clarity on that
now
not only should we be clear on the
pricing but we should be clear on what
the purpose or profit will be used for
it seems only fair that these proceeds
flow back into the maintenance of the
bridge but also into improvements or a
future of redevelopment
having an electronic tolling system for
instance would be a great improvement
and avoid polluting congestion we also
agree that local people that use the
bridge regularly regularly should be
discounted
this is normal for other such toll
bridges and should be the case here
we also agree with the
supplementary edition moving the
operation and control to a separate
company to the proposed rixton and
warburton bridge company could leads
that lead to further toll increases but
also profit potentially moving away from
maintenance and improvement
overall we agree with the consultation
response proposal and we'll be voting in
favor thanks joe thank you councillor
jerome
um councillor evans please
just didn't want to duplicate so
apologies um our group will support this
uh report as it stands we'll just do a
few
uh comments on the report and i will
i've crossed out the duplications that
we've already heard um tolls and road
charging how topical at the moment but
anyway um i think we can all acknowledge
that waters and bridge is in need of
some investment and anyone with even the
basic grass grasp of mass can see there
is no possible way of investing in the
infrastructure to support vehicle
crossings going into the future
and the fight
fines etc um
need to
reflect it's difficult and it's
difficult for this council to argue the
fine scene
in line not that i agree with them but
they seem in line with what we do for
parking charges so it's very difficult
to a little bit duplicitous of our
council but we will support in there
profit from the tolls clearly the
charges should be used for the continued
safe operation of the bridge and ongoing
investment in maintenance software the
ampr cameras but to exclude the
potential for any profit i would simply
say
why would an organization bother to put
the plan together do the investment
manage it on an ongoing basis there has
to be a small amount of profit to
justify his whole existence perhaps as
with some contracts an open book
approach and the cap may assist and
could be organized
the fixed daily multi-trip fee
is essential we can't lose that perhaps
one in line with the current one which
looks like four percent i know that's
two of the twelve and a half people we
do only pay 12 p
and
the tall indexation um
if trafford warrington and peel are
going to go through this process it
would assist to agree a reasonable
metric for handling this we don't want
to be returning to this every two or
three years we need to see this through
the next 25 50 maybe even 100 years i'm
sure
richard rowe and the team and the
warrington team can arrive at a metric
and actually just pin it down once and
for all
and the concessions for locals are
essential they use they have to use the
bridge and there's good uh systems in
place in runcorn
and so i'm sure it's not beyond the the
width of the three parties to come up
with a reasonable discount for the
locals and
and i do wish our council would ex
exercise the same amount of rigor to our
own fee increases that they've exercised
to this it's a good job it's a good
report it's thorough and please think of
our residents when we're doing our
budget and have the same amount of rigor
perhaps a tad of hypocrisy lying here
but our group will support us thank you
thank you councillor evans uh
counselling you please
thank you mayor
and it's important for me that people in
locality to warburton bridge are heard
in this situation
residents of carrington partington
warburton lim earlham caddyshed
warrington and beyond have been united
by years of stress and anxiety brought
on by the increasing traffic issues
posed by delays while waiting to pay to
cross the toll bridge
air pollution caused by stationary
traffic outside homes for hours each day
delays to working people traveling to
and from work families sitting in cars
for hours going to and returning from
school children forced to complete
homework in standstill vehicles because
it will be too late to do so when they
return home delays to skeletal public
transport leaving residents waiting for
long periods in traffic fumes or
choosing not to venture out unless
absolutely necessary in another socially
isolated trafford community
the unacceptable road conditions causing
damage to vehicles the toll booth staff
in some cases teens
earning some extra money around
education are bearing the brunt of
frustrated travellers feeling at the end
of their tether with the daily monotony
and then most tragically an ambulance
unable to get through the traffic at the
speed necessary to potentially save the
life of an elderly and much-loved
resident
in need of medical attention all of this
while it is 12 pence per crossing at the
toll a maximum of 25 pence per day with
a day ticket
the proposal to increase this to one
pound per crossing is unacceptable
anyone needing to cross the bridge a
minimum of twice a day for five days per
week will need to find over 500 pounds
per year to do so this really sticks in
the throats of those with little choice
but to use the total bridge for whatever
reason
for 131 years the manchester ship canal
company have collected a toll on profit
and now this proposal from peel ports
will pass on the bill of six and a half
million pounds for much needed works to
repair warpertonbridge to the very
people who are experiencing disruption
pollution and anxiety because of it
all of this without any guarantee that
the proposed anpr system will stop the
daily delays and the tailback traffic
making lives difficult for our
communities the only thing truly
guaranteed by this
this is hefty fines for anyone who does
not pay the increased toll
i therefore back all of my labour
colleagues and support all of the
objections listed in the report thank
you mr mayor thank you councilman
councillor but
thank you man
i won't
comment on the supplementary because not
really any time to look at it so i'm not
commenting on that one but
uh i'd like to ask you what percentage
of users are responding and what was the
pattern of usage
that was done by the council on this
what evidence has the council used to
make its case other than randomly
stating corporate priorities of
supporting people out of poverty and
addressing the climate crisis
clearly there will be a need for a
reasonable rise in the toll to cover the
level of investment in upgrading the
bridge the surrounding infrastructure
automation and the operational
maintenance costs however i agree there
should be some form of cap or regulation
of the toll charges tolls are charged in
other parts of the uk motorists have the
choice of using alternative routes or
modes of transport
it does smack of double standards and
hypocrisy by this labour administration
in hammering residents with increased
parking charges in other parts of
trafford where local residents are
trying to use their local shops to keep
businesses going
whilst i agree with the gist of the
recommendations in having some form of
cap or regulation of the toll charges on
this bridge the increase proposed is not
unreasonable
clearly there is need for a reasonable
rise in the toll to cover the level of
investment in upgrading the bridge
the surrounding infrastructure
automation and for operational
maintenance costs
it does however expose this labor
administration's discriminatory policies
towards the southern wards in the
borough whether it's refuse collection
or in this case the glaring divide of
hiking or parking charges for local
residents and shoppers in these parts of
the borough where they are trying to
keep the shops on their high street
alive it's no use this council offering
coverage related government grants to
businesses while trying to keep them off
the by hiking the parking charges at the
same time protesting the proposed
charges on the toll bridge
the cost of parking in town centers is
set to rise to two pounds for the first
two hours
with the maximum charge rising to six
pounds
the able but elderly demographic in the
borough has been completely ignored
residents parking permits are set to
increase from 41 pounds 75 to 47 pounds
50 per year
so much so for taking account of local
residents
unless of course this in part of a
border which finds it felt viable to use
the bridge to go for work or shopping
over the other side in warrington
further double standards have appeared
in the appointment of amy by tfgm to
supply the electric vehicle charging
network for the city region
conditions state that
leaving the site you know the the car
scheme which is halted it's deemed
necessary to have to pay as you charge
fees to cover costs
ensure sustainability a reliable network
and enable increased investment
why is that justified for council tfgm
to impose and without setting any limits
but not for private sector company for
exactly the same reasons even though it
can be capped and regulated
2.4 of the plan also continues considers
the requirements for future bridge
upgrades and the improvement and ongoing
maintenance of the approach roads
why can the contested unadopted sections
of the approach
be maintained by some form of
s103 agreement type uh situation where
they are you know
compelled to do those improvements
whilst one can agree with most of the
points in this report including capping
and regulation of toll charges and
concerns around level of tolls relating
to indexation and concessions i do
believe comparisons will be made with
the council's own charging practices in
other areas however we will endorse this
report thank you
order please please
council rad said i think you wanted to
make a comment
[Applause]
with colleagues from the salford side
of the canal and they're actually just
as alarmed about this navy angry about
this they have poorer communities and
it's that link between i think although
it is it with the canal being quite wide
you would think it stepped up with the
prices at the moment it is they really
uh i thought like communities working
together but this could actually
completely split those communities a bit
more than what they are split at the
moment and making it
much more harder for their poorest
people to come uh kind of comment on
council what that never had been so
ridiculous in my life in fact i think it
completely got through with the topic i
think he should have been allowed to
carry on and say no because it's nothing
absolutely to do with the report that's
on the table and i think i'm i was very
frustrated about some of the silly
comments there and all that has been
i've never heard anything so silly i
mean i've appreciate it comes from the
richest areas of the world and it
doesn't have an understanding of some of
the poorer communities and how something
like this can actually really affect
them but i suggest he does take a step
back and actually uh actually look at
those people who will actually suffer as
a result of this i think it is quite a
devastating increase and and
some of these will make more than one
trip a day and i mean something like
that is gonna really really impact upon
them i think that some members perhaps
should reflect on that one and then and
the impact this will actually help them
and it will split uh both sides of the
canal there who actually are really i
think we need to bring together because
both really proud communities i think we
have to work together and this will not
help with that thank you mr matthews
thank you councillor i'd said any of
those members wishing to speak
councillor wetton
councillor holding
the communities within my ward on this
matter and i believe to a large extent i
have captured their mood on
the idea of this change to the toll
uh before i
go into that i would just say unlike the
greens i would refrain from yielding any
points to the ship canal company
peel our strong and wily adversaries
and will exploit any points conceded to
their advantage
now some of us on this council will have
heard the mantra what peel once peel
gets
it was often suggested in planning
committee in those days of trafford
center expansions
and even the sensitive issue of the
barton power plant
though obviously that one fell off their
wish list
at least at those times we were dealing
with new ideas new new plans and new
concepts
but for
but to appeal tonight we should refer to
them as the manchester ship canal
company owned by peel
and what i see in this case is an
established
piece of local infrastructure with an
appropriately low cost for usage
with quite some importance to a number
of traffic residents particularly in the
warbert and dona massey and partington
areas
importance for those people going about
their typical daily travel
they're probably simply taking their
quickest route to the m6
or to liverpool
in my view for the ship canal company
this application to government is in
effect seeking the power to raise
attacks
raise a local tax and have the power to
increase it
and i put it that way because this
bridge is of an age such that it was
open before any living person now was
born
this is not a sparkling new bridge like
mersey gateway
a 600 million pound bridge
yet they manage with a two pound toll
this is an established feature
of our roadscape
and by that very aspect
of it being established it adds nothing
new to our world
local people alive today have always
used it it's always been there for them
so for these new
power grabbing plans to be given life
local people will in effect
be taxed to use something that was
always there to use at a convenient cost
i don't doubt that the ship canal
company will plead that they need the
money
need to spend money on the bridge
something they should have done before
now
to them i would say
you know you should have done it sooner
and it is much more appropriate for it
to be funded by the very infrastructure
peel and ship canal infrastructure
that requires a high bridge in order to
operate properly
the ship canal as i understand it is
still a profit maker after all these
years
so that business should be supporting
the bridge that is essential to its
operation
so what about the impact on a regular
user of the toll bridge
we'll we'll see lots of statistics
associated with this subject and i did
some of my own
i've had to redo it since the
clarification of the the 80 elements so
it might not be
actually
right on the spot with my percentages
but
a five days a week user of the bridge
will currently pay 60 pounds i'm giving
him four weeks holiday a year
that sixty pounds increases to
four hundred and eighty pounds per year
which i think is seven hundred percent
increase
two cars from the same household using
the bridge every working day home and
return
creates an increased cost to that
household an increased cost
of 960 pounds per annum
and yet they're not buying the bridge
for that
they're renting it
for just long enough to cross it
that scale of new expense for a
household changes lives
and not for the better that scale of
money moving differently
starts to change the local economy
and valuable though the bridge is
as we've heard from the previous speaker
it's not always a good neighbor
certain conditions prevailing can mean
traffic hold-ups and these can impact
upon wilberton village and the residents
they have to
develop the art of knowing whether it is
safe to leave home by car knowing that
they might not get back without joining
a traffic jam
imagine the insult to injury then if
you're required to pay the proposed new
toll
knowing that the same bit of road might
actually prevent you from getting home
in reasonable time
i would just make a comment about the
proposals on bylaws because the ship
canal company also seek to create the
power to create bylaws they want to be
able to create bylaws to impose their
rules
onto people using this bridge
i suppose some may say that that is
appropriate because it's their bridge
but for me it is not appropriate for a
business to acquire the power of the law
to bolster their chosen rules
whilst operating a relative monopoly
i would conclude on the bylaws point by
asking
this of those potential bylaws
who creates them
who approves them who enforces them who
deals with appealing them
without satisfactory individual answers
to those and more questions i do not see
how such a power can or should be
awarded to such a business
as we all know we're in an age wherein
government is needing to protect people
from unreasonable financial shocks
we've had furlough schemes and an array
of grants for businesses
all arising from the pandemic
we're facing a crisis with the cost of
energy in which government will be
needing to help people with their home
heating bills
with this
this matter before us tonight on a
smaller scale
some of our population need protecting
from a shock price increase
one that is not inevitable not
reasonable and most importantly is not
fair
there is deep anger in the communities
living around the bridge
about these proposals
so i support the council's action on
this
and let this council go forward on this
issue and protect its residents from
this unfair attack
thank you councillor um councillor
williams way to speak
um thank you chair i don't intend to
speak at length this evening principally
as the salient points have largely been
addressed by other colleagues and ably
so that said i did want to briefly
contribute as the first public meeting i
attended in my capacity as a traffic
counselor following the september 2017
by-election was a meeting of the
warburton tolbridge action group held at
the fuse in partington
what became entirely clear to me that
evening was not just the strength of
feeling helped by residents across
trafford salford warrington and cheshire
but also the huge amount of effort that
has been invested by local people over a
vast period of time into trying to get
mscc to understand the perspective of
local residents regarding the toll
bridge
unfortunately those efforts have not
been rewarded
it could not be clear that the changes
pursued by mscc are done so for a profit
motive they are not in the interest of
local residents but rather corporate
shareholders
mscc as has been highlighted by council
of wetton is under the ownership of peel
ports group a huge multinational
corporate body whose pre-tax profits
have surged from losses of 99.5 million
pounds to a profit of 141 million pounds
over the last 12 months
one would think that some of that profit
could be invested into maintaining
warburton toll bridge rather than
passing costs to local residents of a
huge total hike
the antiquated statutes relied upon by
mscc
to drive through these changes are not
fit for purpose
they do not deliver for local residents
and they cannot play a role in
delivering the sorted transport network
that is required in 21st century britain
now is the time for legislative change
at westminster lastly i would like to
acknowledge the political work
undertaken by other colleagues in
attempting to drive change around the
toll bridge particularly that of the
member of parliament for where's the
annex south barbara keeley and more
recently my city of salford colleague
councillor lewis nelson who has again
attempted to coordinate widespread
objections to these changes
with that chair i commend this report to
council and encourage colleagues to vote
in support of the recommendations this
evening thank you thank you councillor
williams councillor holden we should
speak
you're not going to join us at the front
council holden
okay
yes
you're not missing much don't worry
this is a beautiful bridge
it's been referred to as an elderly
bridge
and that bothers me
because
when i first appeared on this planet
that bridge was a mere 50 years old
and that's nothing
in
civil engineering terms
however i have no problem at all in
voting for this
move
and this proposal
i think the whole process is rather
unfair
but i did mention that
that bridge has been around for
a very long time
or before i arrived and that might
explain why i have a little confusion
and please
bear in mind i'm getting elderly
i'd like to know how
i can explain to
some of my residents
in sale
report explaining why
increased costs should be limited for
the benefit of certain communities
whereas
the steam
process does not seem to be being
applied as we've heard earlier to the
parking charges
which seem to be increasing
memory
um so please
vote for this move let's protect this
beautiful bridge if you get the
opportunity to sail under it please do
and you'll be able to work out why it's
so tall and why it's so old
and why i'm sorry councillor holden can
i interrupt you
members i've given members some leeway
this evening but we still seem to be
going back to parking charges
uh offered by the councilman i don't see
the connection between the two i really
don't so i would like you to just stick
with the issue of the bridge please
council holding
i withdraw that question
i don't want to confuse people i do
think i do think i've been relaxed with
members this evening but
we just seem to be just taking it too
far please thank you council holding
thank you
councillor you like to comment
well i'll be brief um we've heard from
her many of the councillors and council
of wetten there made a very very good
case for supporting this objection and i
think my group is going to be uh
supporting that objection as well
for all of the reasons that's already
been stated i'm not going to go through
them again so thank you very much
thank you councillor new gross um think
council western you'd like to come in
yeah i'm sorry
chair but the temptation is too great
i'm afraid
because time and again
counselor bull addresses this chamber
scrutiny meetings executive meetings and
spouts the most misleading information
imaginable it's like he's been dragged
in off the street not having read the
papers not cognizant of council policy
indeed he's told us this tonight and
told the scrutiny committee the same
last night it is lazy
it is misinformed it is letting down
your residence and you know you've just
accused us of discriminating against the
south of the borough in supporting this
recommendation this evening councillor
but the only discriminatory factor
experienced by residents in the south of
the borough is your representation it is
pathetic
that contribution is utterly pathetic
to come in here
and to suggest
that it is discriminatory against the
south of the borough to charge for
parking
as if we don't have car parks in
stratford at lacey street in irmston at
atkinson road at several other locations
in sale in the center of the borough at
oakfield street and elsewhere you are a
joke
counsellor but i don't know if you fail
to understand
i do not know if you fail
to understand ridiculous
ridiculous hang on hang on hang on
cancel the book
point of order you said there's a point
of order what is your point of order
it's not a point that's not appointed
point of order has to make a specific
reference to a point in the rules in the
constitution
thank you chair i'll continue because
apparently i'm not breaking the right
points because i'm pointing out what was
wrong with every point that left your
mouth
and this is the problem counselor but
it's time and again last night at
scrutiny i've not read the papers
tonight at council sorry i've not read
the papers
can we just have one
do you want to leave
and i feel fairly certain that the
monitoring officer will be taking a view
on what's unfolding here councillor but
and it sharply my behavior that he's out
of order and out of step with the
constitution
is that repeatedly shouting out is in
breach of the constitution counselor but
perhaps you should read that also along
with the paper this evening that you
haven't
read
because the fact is this you've accused
us of discrimination
we have heard that across the borough
residents pay parking charges you've
told us there's no difference
between a profit-making company that
earned as we heard from councillor
williams upwards of 150 million pounds
last year
in profit at the show company and you've
said
how is this different to the council
that has had its budget ravaged by your
government charging for parking
charges
that mean that we don't need to cut
adult social care as harshly as we would
at a time of crisis charges to fund
children's services rather than cutting
those at a time of crisis charges that
fund support that we would otherwise be
cutting for our schools charges that
mean that we are not cutting libraries
leisure centres children's centers
school crossing patrols again this year
in stark contrast to previous years
under different leadership
so look at the end of the day
you can posture and laughably suggested
i was doing this after your contribution
you can posture all you like but don't
ever come in here and call this group a
hypocrite for standing on the side of
residence i'll assume much like the word
discriminatory to an evenly across the
borough imposed charge you don't
understand what hypocrisy means so allow
me counselor but to finish with the two
words that currently best describe
hypocrisy boris johnson thank you chair
thank you thank you
the report has been moved and seconded
can i ask if the council consents or
would you like me to put this to a vote
i think the concerns of that's like an
eye thank you
um
everybody calm down
that then is the end of the meeting i
thank you for your attendance i hope you
enjoyed the rest of your evening
thank you everybody and please keep safe
you